thank you for joining us America here in
the lobby of Ramsey solutions Alan and
Lori are with us hey guys how are you
hey good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Tallahassee Florida all the way to
Nashville to do your debt-free screen
how much have you paid off five hundred
four thousand dollars oh and how long
did this take six years and four months
there you go and making what kind of
money about two hundred thousand right
around that during the course of that
time okay and is that your house and
everything that's the house we're done I
love there just like that completely
debt-free yeah so feeling that I've out
spam well I did what you said I went out
and you know you talk about walking in
the grass I swam in my backyard pool now
you go I'm there are you going all right
that works and it's your pool yeah
that's it every drop of it that's
awesome well congratulations you guys
very very cool this is awesome so what's
this house worth 750 awesome very very
good and how old are you guys 552 all
right and you're and you've been married
25 years 25 years have you ever been
debt-free during your marriage until now
no no I always had and Alan he's the one
that has driven this whole thing and
then I got onboard he's very disciplined
he was a former coach and then became a
high school principal I'm an elementary
PE teacher and it's been an exciting
journey it hasn't been easy but it's
been an exciting journey and we just
paid it off last month and it is like
the biggest weight lifted off we about
six years ago we got caught in that
thing called good enough syndromes what
I call it I think your book mentioned it
but we've been on step six for many many
years
enjoy paying cash for trips and cars but
we always had that mortgage sitting out
there we just kind of said well we'll
just we'll just let that sit and just
pay that every month and then the
economy fell 2009 and we did exactly
what you said we didn't touch anything
of course everything roared back but
when it fell it kind of woke us up I
looked at my portfolio and I was down
38% like most people didn't touch you
think about we had this
monster more than sitting okay and
that's when we came together and it
helps for marriage because we became a
team at that point and we we said let's
get this thing paid off and so I was a
high school principal most of that time
but I developed a little
entrepreneurship on the side
I managed in swimming pools all around
the Tallahassee area well there you go
and so I we targeted that money and
that's how we did it Wow
yeah very fun very fun so Laurie when
Helen sets his mind to something get out
of the way you got it and I was glad to
be a partner in this and I'm the he's a
lot more disciplined and I'm the more
free spirit and I like to spend so it
was took a lot of discipline just to say
no to some things and but let me just
tell y'all it is so worth it it is very
exciting to be at this point six years
later you don't have a mortgage or
anything right you're sitting on
three-quarter million dollar house it's
paid for I mean if they did talk I mean
more I'm just we're the same age you
know if they if they told us when we
were kids if that's where we'd be
sitting at fifty five or something we'd
have been going no way you know but boy
I'll tell you what you put a plan in
place and you do the step by step
process you'll get there you'll get
there it's very very real quick both of
us have parents that modeled not only a
great faith foundation that we have but
also just paying cash for things and so
even early on in our marriage both of
our families had those same values but
you know we kind of get off track
throughout our marriage but it's been
exciting to see that come around Dave my
dad was a very successful football coach
in the state of Florida and he gave me a
book when I was young called see at the
top mm-hmm and the principal's in that
book I've just lived by and and I think
everybody can this is a very doable
thing yeah Ziggler's book yeah fortunate
enough to hear him speak for we passed
made a big difference and just your
encouragement every trip we went on we
were always listening to you on the
radio and not anyway so just that
encouragement of having hearing other
people's stories is so motivating and
encouraging too so it's a big part of it
so what do you tell people the key to
paying off the house is what's the
bottom line secret of the process well
perseverance is everything and you know
we all can't be big fast and strong or
have the academics but we can
here's a character trait that everybody
can have and that's that's what we do we
don't quit on anything we both the
runners and I think we realized six
years ago that we hadn't crossed the
finish line yet ah and so we said look
this cross finishing like we do in these
marathons we run and that's what we did
the perseverance yeah that's fine you
guys are awesome very cool very well
done I love it what a great story all
right Allen and Laurie Tallahassee
Florida five hundred and four thousand
dollars paid off in six years and four
months making a couple of hundred a year
to do it they are debt free house and
everything count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one just
cross the finish line I saw it I saw him
break the tape that's awesome guys well
done well done man that's great